we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p i have a voicemail
today from what could be one of the
wackiest
most uninformed conspiracy theorists
we've ever heard from
get the children out of the room and
listen to this
hi david i'm a nurse myself i live in
florida
and my name is vivian and i'd like to
say that you
are a fool right and yes the elections
were fraud
trump won by a landslide this was
all a confiscation to
steal the election from uh from trump
biden is a crook he is corrupt
so is his family and so are a lot of
members of the democratic party they
sold us
to the chinese for the most part they
don't really give a rest
but about our country okay
so i am 100 agree
with trump i think that interview with
kill me
was excellent and people like you and
cnn and msnbc
and nbc and all your stations that
everybody basically report the lies
okay and they shouldn't even be called
reporters
because you're all in the pockets of
soros bill gates and people like him
all right it's disgusting what you're
doing to this country
and and the fools that listen to you
that believe you
it's really a darn shame
you should be ashamed of yourself for
calling yourself an american
people like you shouldn't even live in
this country okay
don't change our country you've done
enough harm with your
stupid-ass lies so this is this is
essentially
the this is proof that we have a
multi-generational problem in this
country
okay um that doesn't get fixed you
you're not gonna change that person's
opinion right essentially what you need
to do is
maybe someday they'll learn something
and maybe their kids will be slightly
more tethered to reality if we improve
circumstances and maybe their kids like
it's multi-generational in that
voicemail she says
trump won biden is a criminal biden's
family is criminal
the democrats sold us to china all news
stations
tell only lies um i'm funded by george
soros
i'm funded by bill gates it's it's a
90-second voicemail
and there's about eight different
baseless conspiracy theories
with anti-semitic undertones of course
and
you know everything else you can't fix
that by
saying hey maybe we regulate fox news or
you know what like
the the takeaway is the country is
deeply sick
and there's a lot of people that are
very very sick and
you can't fix that quickly it's sad it's
very sad but you just can't fix that
quickly
we've got a great bonus show for you
today i'll see you then
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently checked
out the book podcast marketing strategy
by daniel rolls and kieran rogers
and so useful so particularly applicable
to what i'm doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video